Alex Chalk's going to be the new Justice
secretary he is the MP for Cheltenham
he's on the sort of liberal wing of the
party uh he is currently a defense
minister he's a close Ally of
um the Prime Minister
and so this is a sort of appointment if
you like for Rishi Suna where he's
really Shoring up losing a close
Lieutenant an ally and replacing him
with someone who is in his Circle and
whom he trusts so Alex chalk coming in I
mean Alex chalk is kind of in that gang
of people such as Mel stride the work
and pensions Secretary of State and also
John Glenn who works at the treasury
Grant Sharps there's there's a number of
them
um who have been kind of key uh figures
for Rishi sunak in recent weeks so he's
given a promotion putting into cabinet
someone that has he lose someone he
really trusts putting in someone that
really is one of his people